how much did you get for your last deal
that you sold 20 000 and a wolves box
ticket property at the end of the day is
a numbers game the person that makes the
most phone calls is always the person
that wins we're charging 400 pounds a
night and how much rent are you paying
for the apartment one thousand eight
hundred at University of stuff it's a
lot of academic stuff when I'm training
people it's like let's do it we found
this off Market piece of land we
negotiated it down from a million to
665. the build would be about 1.2 and
then it's going to be worth 2.7 at the
end what will the profit be on that then
just over 800 Grand I'm not a half hour
sort of person I mean they're all in or
I'm not and people come up to us and say
like oh thank you Chris and darcia are
having an input into the way my life
went that feeling is not much of a
better feeling is there
Chris and Darcy the happy couple super
successful Super Rich here today to
hopefully share some massive massive
golden nuggets and how to become
successful in property so welcome to
winners on a Wednesday thank you for
having us excited me so we're like
really good friends and um I mean Chris
in fact why don't you just introduce
yourself how did you get into the whole
world of property yeah my my journey was
was fun it was exciting there was a guy
who moved to my secondary school we kind
of became friends at secondary school
and we were in the same classes Elliot
Spencer you probably you know him but
everyone else probably would have heard
of Elliot great guy great guy but we
were in the same classes at school and
they weren't the the top classes they
weren't the bottom but they were near
the bottom right so we weren't the
smartest kids we weren't the most
intelligent but we were you know we were
okay anyway we became good friends at
school and college and Elliot went off
to do a plumbing and I went into into
the care sector and a couple of years
later anyway I seen Elliot I bumped into
in the pub and I said oh what are you
doing now I've seen you on kind of
Facebook and Instagram and it looks like
you're doing really well he was like I
do I do property might I said what do
you need in property yeah
that's for clever people that's for rich
people what do you mean he goes no no I
didn't I've done it I can do it I said
tell me more so he started telling me
about about you and crash courses and
the one pound events and the training
and deal selling I was like what is deal
selling you know I didn't have a clue
what it was and uh anyway he convinced
me to come to a crash course
um and then I paid for the Advanced
Training some of your Advanced courses
and it absolutely blew my mind I mean
Elliot he sold over I think there's over
200 deals now and when he said that I
did the maths and I thought this guy's
not smart he's from where I'm from we
have the same friends like I can do this
right you know so that that was my I
just that I was like what year was this
was I think 2018 maybe 2019 around sure
so quite a few years ago yeah and you've
gone on to grow a huge you know business
portfolio and Darcy as well like because
you guys met on the on the train we did
we did so how how did you get into the
world of property yeah so my story is a
bit different so I was 19 at the time I
was doing a degree apprenticeship with
an investment Bank you know I had a good
pass set out for me but I saw you on
YouTube and I thought I need to come
down to one of the crash courses you
know they're only a pound and I was
always interested in property so I came
down to one of the pound courses and I
became very obsessed very quickly you
know and I got addicted to you to
properties training so I went on but
like Chris did the Advanced Training
um found a real you know Niche for
service accommodation that I loved so I
started building up my portfolio with
that then obviously I met Chris at one
of them yeah I'm not like a predator
like I feel like a weight in it can we
just talk do you remember when I called
you about oh yeah this was like two in
the morning it was 2 A.M in the morning
me and Chris has been out yeah like
clubbing yeah we've been yeah we've been
out clubbing driving home talking a bit
of business and whatever and uh yeah
I'll let you tell them tell them yeah
from your perspective yeah so from my
perspective I was a friend
I was at a friend's house in Bournemouth
where I was living at the time and we'd
also just been out and I got home and I
saw your name calling me at 2AM and I
thought Samuel never calls me at 2AM I
mean I know you're dedicated to your
students but like it was like a real
dedication so anyway I pick up the phone
I'm like you know hello like is
everything okay and you straight away
you were like so um you know I'm on my
own which straight away I was like
definitely with someone I don't remember
saying that yeah little do I know you
Chris have you seen that did it well
yeah I would never lie it was maybe I
stepped out the car it was more just a
you know it was between me and you okay
yeah you probably didn't really know of
me then no I did okay okay no I'd seen
you about but you know I didn't know of
you and then you were like kind of
saying that obviously I'd grown up in
portfolio I was doing well in property
and did I want to you know come on and
help out at some of the events and blah
blah blah next thing you know I'm at the
events and then that's where yeah
because me and Chris were talking and he
was like who's Darcy who's that girl on
winners on a Wednesday because you don't
win as long as they're already you were
smashing it doing rent to rent service
accommodation you know young he's like
who's that and I was just like let me
see if I can get her to one of the
events I can hook you up and now you are
getting married congratulations thank
you you moved into a big beautiful white
Mansion Just across the road from here
yeah next to my house yeah and um
business is booming so it's just like a
match and even Elliot Spence the guy who
talked about he married my PA no yes
how many people have I married if
anyone's single
property yeah yeah become a property
investor it will all pan out so tell me
about deal selling right because I know
that was kind of what you started off
doing you started with rent to rent you
were deal selling what is deal so deal
selling is where you take a property a
good property deal you find it you
actively go there and secure it for a
certain price and you then pass that
deal on to an investor somebody with
money essentially for a fee usually
around three thousand pounds depends on
the size the deal but usually around
three thousand how much did you get for
your last deal that you sold the last
one we did was was twenty thousand
pounds twenty thousand oh twenty
thousand and a wolves box ticket to go
because I spot wolves right so the guy
threw in a wolves box ticket for me to
go and watch the matches because it's
all about sales right I was obviously
trying to sell him but he was also he
knew I liked wolves and I liked football
so he said look I'm Gonna Give You
twenty thousand because we originally
wanted 30. yeah it yeah but what was
this deal so essentially it was a kind
of straightforward big buy to sa so
there were six apartments in Chester
right by the Racecourse that were
already been running a service
accommodation for years and they were
making like 120 Grand a year we saw all
the figures we verified it did a lot of
groundwork on it and we negotiated the
price down to I think it was it was 900
in the end and he wanted over a mill
right um but we said look we'll we'll
buy them all and to be fair at the time
we were like this is a killer deal like
we would have had it had we not been
tied up and too busy in other things but
we thought you know what since the
training we're not going to let a deal
go twice like this yeah that's when it
then came in being a deal sourcer and
being a property investor go hand in
hand because if you're a property
investor I know you guys are investing
in property actively you're just buying
a piece of land as well at the moment
yeah but if you're out looking for deals
yourself anyway you're gonna find stuff
that doesn't quite work for you or
you're gonna it's like when you're
waiting for a bus and suddenly three
come at once yeah you know you're
looking for property deals and then
certainly three come at once to to just
flush down the drain the deals that
don't work for you doesn't make any
sense makes no sense and this is the
thing like you said you're out there
looking for deals and you're doing
viewings also if you're in the right
Network in the environment like we come
to your your programs and the events
we're meeting people all the time we're
always putting ourselves out there I
mean if I sound harsh it wasn't that
hard was it it was like we got a great
deal I met someone the other week or I
know would love this deal lives in the
area let's just put them together and
yeah when I mean 220 000 pounds off that
was a bit like that's just almost feels
silly it's like a man like a month
salary yeah yeah
but still you know we didn't do that
much work right you know we didn't you
know it was like you say it was pretty
easy for us when you have the right
education and you know what you're doing
and you're in the right circles it's not
difficult I'm an investor I want a deal
I'm gonna give you the objections and I
want you to tell me what you would say
Okay Okay so let's take that that 20
grand deal that you sold for 20 grand
right I'm an investor you've just hit me
up and said hey I found this apartment
Block it's worth 1.1 million I've
negotiated it for 900 that's 200 Grand
below market value and all I want is 20
grand sounds interesting could you give
me some information yeah of course what
information would you like to know I
just want to know uh the address please
the full address so in terms of the
address it's not something that I can
give to you at the moment if you would
like to see it and you would like to
know whereabouts it is then I'm more
than happy but we do need to take a
small fee up front and have an NDA sign
just because it is off market and we
have got it you know much below market
value I can tell you that it is in
Chester it's right near the race courses
the property itself been running a
service accommodation for the past five
years and we have all the stats and
figures to show that it's been making a
profit of minimum 10 thousand pounds per
month so the area itself is very Central
it's very brilliant the actual strategy
has already been working for years it's
simply a change of ownership and what's
your finders for 25 000. you're do you
want 25 Grand literally if you just
introduce me to one deal that sounds a
bit steep you may see it as steep
however compared to the ratio of the
money that you're going to making and
the value that this deal is you're going
to be owning it so you're going to have
an 1.1 million pound portfolio added to
you with an income of ten thousand
pounds a month so it may seem steep but
for the ratio of what you're getting we
think it's actually very fair price well
I guess you've knocked off 200 Grand I
mean I need to do my market research and
I need to see that it really is worth
1.1 million before I pay any money so I
mean we're about to maybe get a viewing
or something on it while I kind of do
all my research yeah of course you know
we're more than happy to arrange a
viewing but again that will come down to
signing an NDA you know it's business
for us and we've put a lot of work into
this and done a lot of due diligence
therefore we need to know that if we're
going to let you view this property and
it's something that you want to go ahead
with we need some sort of commitment
your side right and once we have that
what do you need from me we need an NDA
signed and we need five grand up front
brilliant entry so you did 5000
you're really good by the way I can see
why you guys are killing it in business
if I pay you five grand and then I don't
like it then what happens because I'm
not paying five grand up front and then
potentially the property is terrible and
then losing five grand that's not fair
no of course and we understand that as
investors ourselves you know you don't
want to be putting money down the drain
therefore that five thousand pounds that
you pay now you'll have it back within
14 to 21 days if there are any issues
and you wouldn't like to go ahead with
the deal we are so confident that this
is such a brilliant deal and if it
weren't for other things going on in our
career we would actually invest in it
ourselves if for whatever reason within
those 14 days you encounter a problem
you don't like it five grand refundable
says it on the contract and is legally
binding and how long do I have to decide
if I want to pay the remaining forty
thousand those 14 days so I've got 14
days to make up my mind for sure yeah if
I want it if I want the money back give
me back yeah all right out of role play
for a minute firstly can you sell like
that as well no that's incredible
on a good day
he's brilliant yeah Darcy you were 19
when you first started in property yeah
how did it happen exactly it wasn't the
easiest Road for me I'm not gonna lie so
like say I started out the crash course
um how was the crash course
incredible it you know it's the whole
reason genuinely that I'm here today it
was where I began my property Journey
you know I met so many incredible people
obviously seeing you live was weird for
me because I'd just seen you on YouTube
and I learned so much in just a day for
a pound and I thought if I can learn
this much in a day imagine how much I
can love when I go on and do Advanced
Training and really take this seriously
sure so I did the crash course and I
went home and obviously I was you know
on a big big high and I was speaking to
my family and I was like this this is
what I want to do like I've made up my
mind like I don't want to be an
investment banker I don't want to do a
nine to five like I want to do property
so anyway my family being protective
they were like well don't rush into
anything you know just just calm down
see how it goes I didn't listen to her
advice
and I quit my job and I quit my degree
oh I know which I was doing very well in
at the time but I was like if I'm gonna
commit I want to be a hundred percent
like I'm not a half ass sort of person
I'm either all in or I'm not so anyway I
quit that all my friends or my family
weren't happy I had many arguments with
my parents now I understand it came from
a place of love and care but at the time
I really didn't see that so once I
committed myself 100 it was just like a
snowball because I had all this time and
all this education from you and meeting
all these new people to just really go
at it with property so that's exactly
what I did I was on the phone every day
to agents to landlords I was going on so
many viewings and property at the end of
the day it's a numbers game the person
that makes the most phone calls is
always the person that wins right so I
just adapted that sort of mindset and
thought if I get into a daily habit of
doing a certain amount of things I'm
gonna get results and I came onto your
Advanced rent to rent service
accommodation and HMO training
and you being the brilliant teacher you
are straight away we're like right
here's a script go and call people and I
was like what on Earth so anyway I did
the task and I got five viewings um
within half an hour which I was very
happy with and one of those viewings was
my first essay deal yeah it was that's
something as well with the training at
University and stuff well not that I've
ever done University but it's a lot of
academic stuff yes whereas when I'm
training people it's like let's do it
pick up the phone and people like
yourself from an academic background are
shocked yeah because I'm like here's the
rent to rent script
everyone to practice turn into your
neighbor practice is everyone
comfortable great get your phone out but
oh so many people go to the toilet
stick in the room get your phone out
call five people and say that and and we
force people to and you got five
viewings and then where was that first
deal that you got so it was in
Portsmouth right near gunwhalf Keys it
was a two-bed apartment that I still
have to this day makes about a thousand
pounds a month the rent's pretty cheap
um great cleaning team in place and
never had any issues how do you
systemize the business because I know
it's for you it's quite passive yes very
passive you know it's one thing to be
able to get properties is another thing
to actually be able to have passive
income that is very very different so
what I was taught Again by you and your
team is systemization so we use in my
opinion the best channel manager that
automates pretty much 99 of things my
cleaning teams I try to manage the use I
use uplifting nice yeah really good one
and my cleaners I call them my
superheroes you know they're my eyes and
ears they're brilliant they're the ones
that are actually how did you find them
cleaners believe it or not I love
Checker trade don't I yeah I'm the
latest one we did um Facebook
Marketplace as well yeah how do you find
cleaners on Facebook we just literally
we were struggling a little bit when we
find a good cleaner in our latest one in
sandbank so I went on Facebook just
typed in any local cleaners and we got
about 30 responses and they've been
incred
do you make more money from your service
accommodations or from your property
developments oh development for sure but
I guess it's different type of thing
yeah very different how much do you make
on your Enterprise oh they probably make
us about 10 grand a month I'd say
where was your last rent to rent that
you got where's your area now that
you're focusing on Sunday really yeah we
love something is that like not very
seasonal though no we we are now getting
bookings for November and December as
well so it's a tourist attraction and we
do that we only did that project mainly
because we we go into some banks and it
wasn't I mean obviously for a little bit
of money but the money side of it has
been does it make good money yeah talk
to me about the last deal that you got
inside Banks which is now live and how
much it makes now it works I mean so at
the moment through the summer we're
charging 400 pounds a night to stay in a
two bed damn yeah I think one of your
friends oh mate that's another story
that's a funny story so basically I'm in
sandbanks because I go on holiday there
sometimes and I was staying this is this
is a while back now this one I was
trying for my Rob Moore fight so I was
just staying in some hotel but then my
dude my boxing trainer I was like hey
can you come to stand backs for the week
train me he was like yeah I'll come so I
so I said to him you can sort your own
accommodation out I'll just reimburse
you said fine so I'm chatting with him I
said where are you staying and he says
oh I'm staying in this beautiful
apartment it's like right on the beach
it's amazing and I was like oh nice and
then he said um
it's a bit though I said I said is
it I said why is that and he goes I feel
like I'm the first guest like the the
TV's still in the box
um it just feels a bit rushed like
things aren't quite ready there's a bit
of just beyond the Wardrobe and I was
like oh wow and then I can't remember
how I found out I think you he he he he
messaged Justin he's saying something
about towels or something because
confession he was the first guest in
there
and like Darcy's obviously very
professional and she's like look we need
a couple more weeks just and I'm very
much like let's just get it man you'll
figure it out yeah so he was after that
he met anything he needed towels I think
you said to me oh my guest is actually a
boxer with something yes I'm like he's
not my guy and then we found out it was
oh this dude's gonna slate our apartment
Santa's gonna tell us off because we
haven't done a good job I told him I
told him to leave a good review anyway
he did his apartment was good and then
he asked us how to do it didn't he he
actually waited until he finished his uh
stay there he waited he said like you
teach me how to do this guys
you don't own the apartment you just
control it yeah yeah so 400 pound a
night yeah through the summer and how
much rent are you paying for the
apartment
that's nice man and that's like when you
get right near the beach as well like
that yeah like I said we we wanted to go
there all summer and it's been so hard
to actually go because it's just been
it's been 100 occupancy we haven't even
been able to enjoy it and you're how old
are you now Darcy I'm 22. 22. how 22.
do you have the experience and have
built up the portfolio that you've got
like what's your super hack what's the
what's the the secret
I wouldn't say there's any super hack I
always just I've always said I hate
people that moan and make excuses I find
them the most boring people I always say
you know I never saw my age as an issue
and you know I've had women come up to
me and say oh if you found it really
hard being a young woman in property but
I always say to them if straight away
you're coming up with that excuse you're
not going to get where you want to get I
never thought of it as oh I'm only 19
and I'm only a young girl it's like no
no no I'm an adult I know what I want to
do with my life and I know now how I can
get it so I just need to do it sure and
I can vouch for that because I I see you
do this and what does he's so brilliant
at and one of the things I love about
you is like obviously when when there's
on a Wednesday right now and it's all
great but there's been times where it's
hard like of course you know there's
times where we haven't got the deal we
wanted or didn't get the investor right
and every time darcio if something
doesn't go quite well she'll take a
moment and because she's dejected but
then she'll just go well every
millionaires had had failures I've just
got to keep going yeah now she says
every billionaire but um you know so
it's moved on but that is is such an
incredible mindset that you do don't you
you just you take a pause and you go
well everyone's you know everyone's
struggled at one point I've just got to
go on to the next one now I've got to
find the next one yeah and that is is
brilliant and it's one of your best
qualities that's amazing what do your
friends think Chris about your new fancy
house it's mixed it's me it's so
interesting I threw a party you came to
it and it's interesting because half of
them are super proud and you know they
they love what I'm doing and they're
asking what they can do and there's this
other half that I love them but I can
just see a little bit of I'm going to
say it jealousy a little bit jealousy a
little bit of emptiness and you know
they're not I don't know if they're as
happy for me as I would be for them and
I don't know if that's because of the
position we're in now that we just want
everyone to win I'm trying to cast back
to five six years ago when maybe we
didn't have all that money would I have
been a little bit envious possibly was I
envious of Elliot
maybe you know like maybe I was not
envious but and I wanted him to pull me
up but yeah it was really uh really
interesting just to see I want to say
though massive respect and kudos to you
guys as well for pulling people up I
want to talk about Uganda and I also
want to talk about what what you do to
give back coming to a lot of the events
as well
um but talk to me about how Uganda came
about and what happened
Uganda was the most incredible
experience
um when I first met you and heard about
your charity work I was like I want to
come out with you and then what was it
like a year ago your living room I
remember yeah I remember it clearly yeah
we got a call from you and you were like
hey guys I'm going Uganda fancy coming
along straight away we were like yes you
were like it's these days that came like
we don't care like we're in we're in
we'll make it so you took us out to
Uganda and that arrival like was wow so
we've been on War I
yeah and we were tired weren't we and
and when we arrived and when we got
there to the school there was what
a thousand children just welcomed us
because of what you've done for them
already and we were associated with you
and they were dancing around it was like
a it felt like kings almost you know it
was absolutely incredible and that
feeling that looks like Goosebumps
talking about it now because it was
there's nothing like that that that that
day that moment is something I'll I'll
never ever forget and you were so
inspired that you donated
um towards the building of school number
two yeah yes which is going to be built
well I think it's actually finished now
is he finished yeah we're finished yeah
the start of November we're gonna go out
there again that's gonna be incredible
next trip are you bungeeing next month
yeah she is oh yeah come on we're live
come on
wait we do it I'll Skydive I won't
bungee oh oh I'm only 22 and I don't
have a Death Wish oh my goodness
skydiving's more scary than Bungie no
I'd rather do that because then I've got
someone behind me with a pageant I can
enjoy it whereas in a bungee you just
got you can't see anything it's you did
a bungee didn't you I did a bungee oh my
God I'm still shaking yeah it's scary
yeah it's scary because you got you
gotta be the one that that throws
yourself off yeah yeah awesome as well
you know you come back to the events um
which I I know you come back for your
own reasons and you do a lot of
networking get a lot of business and
everything like that which is great but
also some massive help for me because
you know the crash courses and stuff
there's so many people that are
interested in doing Advanced mentorship
the academy and me sitting down with
everybody and working out the right
package for them and what can people
afford you know having people like
yourselves who've become really close
friends with is you know I really
appreciate it and you do you guys do a
great job and I know that it's time
consuming and then you spend quite a lot
of time doing that you come to pretty
much every crash course yeah
you're basically there why do you do
that what's that like from someone
that's been through it and then coming
back and helping out what's that like
it's incredible like you know we we bump
into people we bumped into someone in
the gym a few weeks ago and when people
come up to us and say like oh thank you
Chris and Darcy we're having a an input
into the way my life went that feeling
there's not much of a better feeling is
there
um we see it all the time there was a
guy I was speaking to a couple of months
ago and he was from Romania we got into
why he wanted to do deal selling and you
wanted to do the the deal selling master
class and I said why do you want to do
that and he said oh I want a nice car
and why'd you want a nice car so I can
show my family what to do and why is
that important to you and we went I went
deep with him and in the end he came to
well actually there's a lot of Romanians
on the street in London and I want to be
one of the first that shows them there's
a different way you know you don't have
to go on the street selling this that
and that there's a different way so I
felt then it was my obligation to steer
him towards the deal selling masterclass
so he can then take at least if it's
just one extra person off the street in
London that that's my obligation to do
that so I get fulfillment from that as
well from people saying thank you for
for giving me that little push or
talking into doing this yeah that's
that's a huge feeling that's one of the
big reasons I do it yeah a lot of people
don't realize that they do need that
little push over the fence because it is
I understand for most people a bit of a
daunting thing because it's so new but
if we can see someone that you know we
we know what it's like to be in their
shoes we completely understand how
they're feeling in that moment and we
know exactly what advice to give them
based on the experience that we've now
had for the last few years is you know
we have a lot of pregnant women that are
on maternity leave and they say I really
don't want to go back to work yeah and I
really want to get into property but
it's scary for them because they're like
well you know it's a it's a bit of a
risk for me and I'm you know it's nice
calming them down saying but it's
risking yourself and as long as you put
in the right steps you're going to get
the results that you want to see so it's
very very rewarding for us you know
we're lucky that because of the income
and property that we have we have a lot
of free time we want to give back we
want to you know see people succeed and
sometimes push people over the fence
that need it and I always say you may
not like me in this moment but give it a
few months and you'll love me and they
do and they always come back and they
say thank you so much like even Anna you
know bumped into her like yeah it's
incredible oh yeah just today I
interviewed them on Wednesday yeah and
as they were leaving you arrived and the
first thing they said is thank you yeah
absolutely because you were you were the
training advisors that sort of got them
yeah and she was she was emotional when
I was speaking to her at that point in
time she was very emotional and her
husband she was really unsure he was
almost a little bit angry with me I was
a little bit scared he's quite a big guy
and yeah just bumping into them now and
and then you know almost
shaking our hands Thanking us because
they're here now it's the same old
though yeah time and time again yeah
tell me about your development business
development so this is where you know
our vision for our business is now going
is most of our time is on this
development and land so the most recent
bit of land obviously we we started
development by investing in projects
with you yeah you know and thank you for
giving us that opportunity because we
learned so much of you and so much of
Russell you know of how developments
work and the age set and then in the
last let's say six months it's last year
we we felt confident that we can now go
and do one by ourselves so we found this
off-market piece of land negotiated the
heck out of it Chris did what he did
best really good cop Badcock weren't we
so Darcy's very not when we go to these
kind of view and she's very nice and
does her thing very logical and I'm a
bit more like what can you give me for
this piece of land
um it works quite well it does so we
negotiated it down from a million to 665
uh which for us was a massive win got
quite a few Builders quotes and
Architects on board to say the build
would be about 1.2 and then it's going
to be worth 2.7 at the end says what are
you doing with it sixth Bungalows nice
planning already yeah oh beautiful
that's gonna be huge it's gonna be a
really really nice development we've
already got agents saying that there's
buyers we know three people that want to
buy them as well so what will the profit
be on that then just over 800 Grand and
that's concerned if you don't think
there's anything there if you just do
one project like that a year yeah if you
can make you know sort of around a
million a year on that and then you've
obviously got your rent to rent and
stuff which is a nice bit of cash flow
yeah yeah you deal sell it legit but but
you can live really comfortably that's
the goal now is yeah one a month of
these one a month is that right one a
year of these yeah we did another view
in last week wasn't it yeah another
off-market piece of land literally the
street opposite our house yeah you
probably like this one actually yeah
um yeah one of our friends in the area
took us around it and currently it's
like a old house on a big piece of land
and all down the street they've
demolished the house and built two on
the land instead nice new modern they're
worth minimum two mil all the houses
along that street it's like a very well
known she just needs to follow the
pattern doesn't it it's quite a simple
one planning would be easy we know the
MP of our area now we became quite good
friends with him oh wow so yeah planning
would be easy Lich and Brilliant thing
is she doesn't want to exchange until
next May so you don't actually have to
pay for it until next May
so it's yeah looking like another good
potential route to go down I love that
what will be your final pieces of advice
to somebody watching this that really
wants to get into property that's been
watching too many YouTube videos we need
to start doing it what's their next
steps uh mine would be don't just wait
and assume something Good's gonna happen
to you I was always kind of a happy go
lucky guy still am in some ways but you
know I was I worked in a children's home
I played bingo with my gran every month
you know I call my mum every day I was
like consider myself a good guy and I
had that mindset of like something
Good's gonna come you know I've just
gotta wait I'm a nice guy like Karma's
coming right and I think a lot of people
think like that but that's completely
wrong you have to be the one that that
makes stuff happen you have to take the
leap you have to to go to a crash course
you have to get a mentor you have to go
to property View and you've got to be
the one that pushes yourself that would
be my advice don't don't just wait don't
just because you're a good person assume
good things will come because it doesn't
I had I had a tough year before all my
property stuff started and I had to
really dig deep and and push through all
that stuff to go on and do what we've
done now so yeah that'll be mine don't
wait just do yeah I would say similar
like if you know that you want something
and you know how to get it which for
most people was coming to a one pound
crash course I mean if you want
something really bad then you should at
least be willing to sit down for a day
with you and in a great Network for one
pound do that that's where everything
starts
um and yeah just you know I always say
the most dangerous thing you can do for
yourself is nothing if you want a change
then you have to do a change to see it
yeah you can't just wait around you
can't just say oh it's not the right
time there will never be a right time as
I learn the hard way if you want to do
it just do it how do your family feel
now about your success they are very
very happy for us I met your parents for
the first time yeah you did yeah
you know you know really nice to me they
probably wouldn't have said that a year
ago so two years ago when you first
started so with that being said then I'm
Gonna Leave a link in the description
with tickets to the one pound property
investors crash course should people
come along definitely absolutely can't
wait to meet you come down let's meet up
let's do business come meet me spend the
day with me I'll leave a link below just
to pound what are you waiting for I'll
see you there
[Music]